thank you very much I'm very happy to be
here and my talk probably has only one
thing in common with Rhett's to talks
here we have a big data challenge so how
many of you know anything about
manufacturing all right I was okay
that's good I wasn't sure how many
people would understand matter of fact
but all of you I think hopefully all of
you will come away from this talk
understanding there is a big data
channel and associated with
manufacturing where we are today the
other thing is from a website
perspective I have the nimbus website
the other organization i'm going to
reference and a lot of my talk is
reference on smart manufacturing
leadership coalition and that's their
website on the very bottom there so if
you want to find a little bit more about
smart manufacturing leadership coalition
so a lot of one can present is really
information that's been collected from
this consortium of organizations you can
see there's a lot of practitioners or
testbed participants anywhere from Joe
dynamics General Electric General Mills
energy companies pharmaceutical
companies there's quite a range of those
there is also the platform providers and
that's where Nimbus fits in providing
the cloud platform ecommerce marketplace
opens open source type platform for the
data and then you have universities and
then you have some standard
organizations and some government
agencies involved in this and this was
formed because as a point out later is
that getting the data in the right place
in the right form is a huge challenge
president comes to manufacturing so this
is the challenge for manufacturing and
as I alluded to just before is that in
order to smart manufacturing all
information is available when it's
needed where it's needed and in the
forms most useful to drive optimal
actions and responses that's the biggest
challenge today is to get it in a form
and I will mine
why that's a big challenge once you have
the data in a form and in the place
where you can actually get access to it
then you can start applying some of your
techniques manufacture intelligence
throughout the life cycle design
planning and production of the
manufacturing process and some
techniques is you want to get develop a
comprehensive behavioral understanding
of your data and through modeling and
other analytics techniques and one smart
manufacturing is leadership coalition is
interested in is lower the barrier so
more companies can get involved in
getting data in a form accessible so it
can encourage development of
entrepreneurs and a large communicate
access to the data right now most of
datas Praia Terry and very difficult
access to it and most of soft being
developed by automation companies we
need to broaden that up into those folks
are doing at the data analytics would
say dun and Bradstreet could also apply
some of the techniques here for example
so that's why it's very important why we
want to make the data more open this is
the the challenge from the manufacture
and side you probably heard Internet of
Things it's part manufacturing he's
collecting data at all different levels
and if you had a clean slate it'd be
very simply get the data simpler i
should say good today in the right forum
but on the right hand side but the
problem is most of data today is in a
private area form collected by a large
number of automation companies all
different forms and formats and as you
go up to pyramid currently most of data
is bright airy and it's not useful in a
collective sense the goal is to get the
data so that would be able to convert it
the data to information that can be
useful so be able to apply in a smart
manufacturing sense converting knowledge
to wisdom through a collective approach
so this is a generic diagram of a
manufacturing supply chain and what you
would like to do is click data across
the entire supply chain if you focus
actually within just two plant there in
the center there there are lots of seems
there seems actually where the walls are
there actually seems if you ten and
today as you actually more seen has been
generated as they're worried about
security and they're starting to be
different zones of security which also
limits access to the data but let me
give you an example let's take the case
of General Mills so if you want to when
you go to eat a box of cereal at
breakfast you would like to know where
it came from is it GMO is it organic
what's a petty reason not i think it's
not organic you don't maybe we don't
care about that that's fine but you want
to know what the pedigree what's the
province all the data's been collected
is through there so you'll be able to
track that from from the field to the
truck to the storage bin mills to the
train to the factory and you want to
know what's a moisture content is
because they would like to adjust the
moisture content based upon I mean I
adjust their their processing steps
based upon a moisture content and they
would like to track that the entire way
through and an a given trainload I'd say
of a week we'll probably go into
different packages maybe one promotional
package of smaller pack of large package
and then so it gets out to your table
and that same train load week may have
ended up in all different assets you
won't be able to train track that and
the cause of current regulatory
guidelines are coming down you want to
be a well maintained that for at least
two years so you won't have a complete
pedigree of that so how do you collect
all that across that supply change
that's just an example
or a food industry so what is smart
everybody calls their system smart
that's a marketing term or intelligent
okay but in the sense that we're define
I'm finding here is as a deeper
understanding factor process through
modeling analysis it's really from a
practice perspective is using
sensor-based data-driven manufacturing
what this means you need to add
additional sensors strategically in
entire supply chain different places to
in order to do that and that's not
necessarily a comes free and the real
challenge again comes execution is how
do you is the dynamic works tration
decision making a work flows between
multiple environments so i'll show you
later is the channels of time series
data aligning it up and put it in the
right context to be used which is
similar to other things that other talks
have talked about here are examples of
some of the test beds that are being
considered example you can just focus
strictly on the machine line operation
that's very focused that's not across
supply chain that's one form you can
focus on high fidelity modeling like CFD
type analysis you can focus more on day
on the dynamic decisions across the
supply chain and then you also can look
at the enterprise level including
metrics across supply chain and then for
more things like automotive industry
design and planning of your components
your parts or integration in advanced
manufacturing is also a very important
aspect of it to give you a little idea
of examples now Department energy is
funding a project to implement smart
manufacturing across these two cases
here in the case of
Praxair there is a methane reformer on
the left hand side with hundreds of
tubes in there all operating different
efficiencies and there's multiple plants
across the US and across the world and
you would like to be able to optimize
those furnaces so to speak across there
what happens in most cases is that these
furnaces are configured once and left
that way and maybe once in a while
manually tweaked but you really would
like to be able to build a fine tune
that and on the bottom it's the whole
idea of generation of making those
munitions you would like to be able to
minimize mount energy and steps and
amount of milling grinding it takes in
order to make those device and you want
to track the entire way through the
process line so I'm going to hope with
this diagram here exert gives you the
complexity what I'm talking about is at
the micro level at the plant you're
working at a second the minute level
small control loops automation control
machines and there's thousands of
control loops at that point and there's
a lot of automation equipment out there
doing that today but there's lots of
seems from in the flow from one step to
another there are a lots of lots of
seams and data is not necessarily being
collected way it should be across those
seams as you go up to the next layer
there are hundreds of control loops but
they are maybe in hours so it has more
to do with from from the flow of the
product through the scent of the line
let's say and then there's more business
level decisions that have to be made in
days time frame and so what you like to
do is be able to have a smart
manufacturing environment that sits on
top of that and is able to collect data
at all levels
and the challenge is it's not as simple
as that is that this really represents
only one plant a rather sophisticated
plant they're actually in the case of
other cases there may be plants that are
owned by the company or they may have
purchased a plant for another company
they're all different equipment or they
may be using contract plants to do what
they're doing but they want to come out
with a uniform product how do you do how
do you collect data so the data
collection in these different levels
you're interfacing to different tools
different automation companies some data
may be coming in at this at the discrete
level with a single tag and a numeric
value and and that's often a collected
and that historian which we can store up
like 500,000 type tags at a time and
then you now throw in the aspect when I
talk about the general mills case we tie
in supply chain so in one case is
somebody may be handing you a fax with
the moisture content of the week how to
get that in the system and so there's
all different levels of data and types
of data that's coming in there this is
just an example of a lot of the levels
of automation that's out there levels
one and two or sort at the micro level I
talked about before two and three is
sort of like the meta level and four is
more or less the macro level that's sort
of the tools but they are sort of moving
up into smart manufacturer or not there
but the real challenge is is that it's
all stoke plate a vendor cannot
integrate with other vendors and that's
again why the SML c is doing what
they're doing so on the right hand side
here is these different domains use
cases for this as i alluded to this data
is collected here you may be sensor data
and maybe calibration and main
data and maybe production models of
what's expected this is collected let's
say on different discrete time steps
anywhere from seconds on up you then
must a map it and put it in the proper
context and only then can you start
doing some analysis of that and so
currently today there are systems that
are doing this to a certain extent and
in the middle here there is a huge
storage data organization model of which
a lot of companies call historians which
allows you to essentially pull the data
for whatever you want so it's a huge
storage database which you're able to
specify I want this type of data on in
this context under this event with this
plant based upon this event that kind of
thing be able to pull that and get that
data now if you want to go across the
supply chain if you want to go across
mobile plants over months years what you
like to do is be able to be able to push
the right propre data up into the cloud
into a form that real data analytics can
take place and so that is where the real
innovation is going to take place next
in intelligent manufacturing and so the
first step in what we're doing here is
making sure the data defining how this
data gets up here and developing an open
platform up here so that researchers and
companies can develop apps that can
analyze the data and this will be a
first in order get the data in a form
that everybody can get access to and
work with in some cases the companies do
not want to have the data in a cloud
they would prefer to have it with a
narrow plant in that case there you take
the same open infrastructure and they
can host that within their own plan
in most cases we see this as being a
hybrid model where they may do some data
was they're very sensitive about being
processed locally another case that will
be processed up in a private community
cloud so from a processing work flow
perspective here is the diagram I showed
you before you can sort of think of this
in a conceptual form is that you have a
workflow up here or data analytics type
workflow in which you may be doing data
analysis and you may want to extract
different applications or apps from the
marketplace incorporate those and do
your analysis and automatically it
integrates into the cloud platform so in
summary what I'm really talking about is
is smart manufacturing SML c is really
looking at a comprehensive approach to
this this is what the companies really
want to get out of it they want to be
able to go across their supply chains an
agile demand-driven manner i'll be able
to report regulatory constraints
guidelines they'll develop and supply a
higher quality product to the customers
they also want to be able to do in a
sustainable manner especially reducing
energy which is what the dealy project
is all about and the other thing that's
very important is they really want to be
able to optimize across their plants
across the supply chain that is curling
right not now not happening right now
most of companies are may be on to
fine-tuning within a portion of their
manufacturing line some companies that
are more sophisticated or do across
entire plant but very few of them are
gone across multiple plants and across
the supply chain and there's been fast
eddies done that there's a huge payoff
in achieving this type of environment
the other thing that sort of goes
without
saying is that once you have this data
in the cloud like that there's a lot of
things you can do with it so I've
already talked about the data can be
used to explore these different
dimensions here but there's one other
dimensions that's very important and
that is security food safety for example
you would like to be able to know if
there's any unusual events our behavior
taking plate we're not you're generating
energy and the plants going to blow up
or in the case of food you want to know
any unusual event just like we do credit
card processing other words when you
have a data up there the data can be
used in a lot of different ways aniline
that night different ways and and
security is another dimension with the
data can actually be analyzed specially
from an event perspective and it also
helps predict for example if one of your
device's our equipment may be nearing
failure also so it's too interesting
once you have the data it was awful lot
of things you can do with it and that's
what's so exciting about this